ladies and gentlemen hello and welcome
to retro rack and tour live hopefully my
mic is on it's been a while since i've
done this
it's been just a little bit guys it's
been just a little bit so seeing that
uh seeing some of those clips there
was kind of a fun trip down memory lane
so as long as you guys can hear me
give me a thumbs up guys give me a
thumbs up okay we're getting lots of
highs in the chat
i'm serious man i streamed i streamed
for a really long time but you know
every now and then the streamer still
they forget to hit that uh unmute the
mic button you know
sometimes you just forget to hit it
but tonight i think i hit it
it looks like everything's coming in
clear
don't want to don't want to spike the
mic though too
actually uh let me check one thing here
on the filter of the mic
okay good yeah just making sure we got
the limiter on there because we don't
want it to get too too loud
oh man look at this we are all right so
let's see we got gretchen in the chat
mark
joel josh
dylan what's up dylan dylan was actually
the very
first person ever
to join
the youtube channel as a youtube member
it's it's so weird getting used to that
different terminology on twitch it's
like subscribe but on youtube
subscriptions are free
on twitch it's the subscriptions you pay
for so dylan was the first ever
member uh so dylan has access to those
brand new gryffindor ravenclaw oh wait i
mean uh i mean our um our lion emote our
snake emote
badger and eagle emote so let's see who
else we got in the chat we've got um
let's see i said mark already play jd is
here blake shear lots of names i'm
recognizing from the youtube comments
guys so thank you all so much
uh fernandez i never know how to
pronounce your first name
d-u-a-r-t-e
duarte probably
terribly terribly mispronounces there my
apologies too bad i'm from europe it's
my bedtime i'll watch tomorrow
uh let's see we got archie maker in the
chat as well nightly nerd nightly nerd
what is up welcome
thank you so much for stopping by and
hanging out cynics another name that i'm
not sure if i'm pronouncing correctly in
in my head whenever i see you cynics and
this is
c-i-n-i-q-s i may have even asked you
before how exactly do you pronounce it
so if i didn't i forgot my apologies we
got wild panda girl here
we got mary here we got nathan here
ultra blue j j is it ultra blue jr or
ultra blue
junior one of the two i'm not sure
bright eyes welcome
lived oh wait hold on this
this is a long one right here lived or
no lit i bet it's live dance laugh music
love hey that's kind of cool i like that
number one proprietor of hogwarts legacy
news i appreciate that there's there's a
lot of good hogwarts legacy content
creators out there and it seems like
we're growing by the day which is good
to see
seems like uh every day i hop on youtube
there's a fresh new face that pops in as
somebody who is um
making hogwarts legacy content which is
awesome we got john we got wubby we got
ellie here in the chat
demonic one let's see i think we already
said hi to archie laser
laser rio maybe b freshness scotty boy
jason ingram
john again the white wolf fred
we got george we got tren
let's see
and we got dev hey are you do you happen
to be a hogwarts legacy dev by any
chance
10 a.m for you mark oh nice where you
coming to uh coming from i should say
mark
yeah every that's the thing anytime i
comment about
hey where i'm thinking about bringing
back live streams or i want to do live
streams again one of the first things
people always say is they're like oh
that's too late for me all my uk friends
they're like it's it's too late
and i'm like trust me i wish i could do
it earlier i really do but like 8 p.m
eastern for me is kind of the earliest i
could hop on for a live stream
so
it's because i usually i'm at work until
about 5 30 6 every day every weekday
and so then i get home it's dinner it's
play with the kids for a little bit help
get the kids in bed you know take a walk
or something
so there's there's not a lot of time
but who knows maybe one day one day red
exorcist if it isn't just a dad who
likes games and the stories they tell
very close red exorcist it's just a dad
who loves games and the stories they
tell but you almost had it you almost
had it
thank you for saying oh yeah no problem
brisbane australia nice so it's 10 a.m
there awesome we got tm 0-3 watching
from spain
believe we take released it in gamescom
oh man and that one my apologies
that is characters i do not recognize
the only one i recognize is the one at
the front there b
so my apologies but be there i believe
we get a release date in gamescom it's
possible it's possible i'll tell you
what i don't think so because
it seems like sony has this lockdown in
terms of the marketing exclusivity
every time we get major news there's
like a sony component whether it's a
blog post whether it's a state of play
they always have a big big role in it
hi iq warrior what is up dude welcome
good to see you here man it's so awesome
like
i said on twitter and i think i posted i
posted this on the youtube community as
well
i have missed doing live streams and for
those of you who follow me for a while
you probably know the story of why i
haven't been doing them
but for the for the new ones here just
to sum it up really quick so i used to
stream on twitch about three nights a
week
this was like pre-pandemic so pre-2020
did this for many years and just it was
something i did after work just for fun
um and then 2020 happened and had a lot
of time off work and so i said you know
what let's start a youtube channel
let's let's really commit to this let's
really learn it let's really do this and
youtube as you guys have seen by the way
not to sidetrack us too much but we just
hit 25 000 subscribers
which is incredible so thank you guys so
much for that that is that is absolutely
incredible i saw that we were kind of
getting close throughout the day i
thought
dude that'd be so awesome if we hit that
before i go live tonight so i checked
right before i hopped on and we did
indeed we made it guys 25 000
subscribers incredible
so um i know i said long story short so
let me try and shorten it here but yeah
the youtube channel took off well then
i went back to work so i worked for a
library we were closed for a while then
we reopened and so then i had to go back
to work and so all of a sudden all that
extra time i had
it kind of became a choice of youtube or
twitch i had to decide
and i clearly chose youtube and it's
been a couple of years i mean really
since 2020
that
i've committed and said i want to commit
to bringing back live streams because
it's just a totally different feel
getting to interact with you guys in
real time and answer questions in real
time seeing all of you in the chat some
of the names that i see every day in the
comments
uh it's awesome so
thank you all so much for being here
alright so let's get caught up here now
little lady hope the game comes out this
holiday yeah i hope so too i mean that's
still the official word right official
word is still holiday 2020.
1am for william
oh yeah and i saw some people commenting
about the shirt somebody said they love
the shirt and then somebody said uh let
me see here
hold on let me scroll back up
somebody said
a lightsaber a lightsaber behind me no
like
when i was setting this up i really
hoped you guys would be able to see the
full light
but the camera angle here actually i can
do this for right now
i mean now you can see what it is right
it's like the it's like the r you know
and it's in my my logo colors
but
it just didn't quite work out because my
head is way down here
but hey i mean lightsaber that's that's
pretty slick too if you think about it
as lightsaber and then we got link oh
wait this way we got link right down
here oh and then you can see my dog
right there a small piece of my dog
anyway
her name's luna by the way i'll i'll let
you guys guess where that came from you
know just just take a wild guess i'll
guess but yeah somebody was asking about
the shirt so
this shirt was from the
in the lead up to book seven i listened
to two podcasts very frequently
um potter cast
and muggle cast
so muggle cast is the podcast that
mugglenet put out and potter cast was
the official podcast of the leaky
cauldron
and they did a what they call a summer
of seven tour to where they went around
to all these different i think it was a
borders
bookseller which is kind of sad because
i don't think borders are around anymore
um i think that i think they were at
borders
and i went to a live show and they had
merch there
so this was the as soon as i saw this
shirt i was like i gotta have that it's
awesome shirt and it's like it's unique
you know you don't see a lot of people
it's not like something you can go and
buy it universal
so it's it's a fun one it's a fun one
for sure
we got somebody 1am in england
watching from spain that is awesome dirk
says here love your hogwarts legacy
conte hey i appreciate that oh and it
was it was tom who asked the question
about the uh
about the shirt so there you go tom
such a great daddy if you walk with oh
yeah we we love to take walks my kids
today they're like i don't feel like
walking so we we got the wagon out
just carried them around
i'll i'll pull them around in the wagon
for a bit
doncic mvp
watching from france
nice russia when is gamescom
that's a good question
i just like i haven't even put a lot of
um
i just haven't even really put it on my
radar because
i just really don't think we'll get much
there i mean i i'd love to be wrong i
really would
um
from august 1st let's see
no it's definitely not august 1st
why is this not like the first thing
that pops up
when you google gamescom 2022
uh august 24th through 28th
there you go
fred says only youtuber actually watch
when it comes to content for hogwarts
like i say hey i appreciate your support
uh honestly though like i mean there are
a lot of good creators out there so it
and i feel like we all bring kind of
something unique to the table
i watch a lot of them but then at the
same time i try not to watch too much
because
it's this really weird thing when you're
trying to come up with original ideas
because you don't want to just basically
make another video that somebody else
has already made even though we're
covering a lot of the exact same things
so but yeah there are a lot of good ones
out there um
for sure so i definitely encourage you
guys to check them all out
nightwing they're playing it close to
the chest smart i mean they're they're
definitely playing close to the chest
but we're going to talk a little bit
actually let's let me go ahead and
switch scenes here
yo
i forgot i i forgot to set up the alerts
oh man
i didn't set up the alerts on the other
page
anytime anytime you see you're a wizard
harry that is uh
[Music]
that is someone who has subscribed to
the channel but i don't know why your
names aren't popping up
why are the names not popping up
let me see if i can uh get the names to
pop up there
uh let's see let's take that down for a
second
think sony will say release date
december 13th uh it's possible
i feel like december 13th would be the
last
day
if they're gonna release in
this year because let me pull up a
calendar here real quick to make sure
i'm not
december 13th that is
so it's not the tuesday before christmas
because the following tuesday would be
december 20th i mean is that like too
close to the holidays you want to give
people plenty of time to be able to buy
the game before the holidays i'm trying
to remember i feel like smash brothers
melee
on the gamecube was a december release
that might have it might have been right
around
december 20th it's been a long time
though
it's been a long time so yeah maybe they
could get by with december 20th i'm i'm
still
i'm still sticking to december 6th we've
seen that come up a lot more lately but
i did say in the video that i released
today that i
i do think there's still a chance it
gets delayed
i'm sorry i'm sorry guys i really am i
really am sorry i hope i'm wrong i hope
i'm wrong
i'll i'll explain the delay in a second
i'll explain the delay in a second let
me try to fix that you're a wizard harry
first here
because i want you guys to see your
names when you subscribe to the channel
once you see them popping up at the top
there
so yeah i i streamed on twitch for a
while so somebody asked if i'll ever
stream on twitch again
i think so i i do i want to add
i don't want to bite off more than i can
chew which is what happened last time to
where i was doing like three nights of
streaming trying to do two youtube
videos a week and it was just way too
much so we're still doing the two
youtube videos and now i'm gonna slow
i'm gonna try to add this style of show
right here like this talk show like
we're still kind of here at the
beginning we're just chatting then we're
going to get into more of a of a
discussion we're going going to go
through all the latest news we're going
to go through some theories and then
we'll answer questions throughout so
this is going to be more like a laid
back talk show honestly inspired by i've
been watching
expecto goes live streams if you guys if
you love hogwarts legacy and you're not
following expect to go definitely check
out expecto go expecto go is the man
when it comes to
theories on this game i'm telling you he
is constantly coming up with unique
theory and lore ideas but
i love his live streams i love his live
streams i love the vibe that he has with
his chat and i was like man building
something like that i really feel like
the live streams are such a key
component so
shout out to expecto go and somebody
else
just subscribed but we can't see your
names all right here we go i'm gonna go
into my streaming tools here because i i
revamped even though i hadn't streamed
in a while but i kind of revamped a lot
of my like all these overlays i've had
for a while but the alerts and
everything i changed i i wanted them to
work with the harry potter theme the
hogwarts legacy theme instead all right
let's go into alerts here
and let's go into settings and let's go
to subscriber alert
all right let's try in this style
and we'll save that and we'll see how
that looks when it comes back in
and then we can bring back the pc screen
there all right
seth green subscribe oh i see it in the
chat there nice
thank you seth for the subscription here
all right let's try and catch up on some
of the comments here
i'm gonna pop my chat to this other side
oh this is perfect there we go
expect to go is awesome andrew i love me
some expect i'll go jay rossi
what is up j rossi a long time supporter
jay rossi has a name i have been seeing
for a very long time in the comments
thank you so much
don't you dare say that dylan says
that's got to be about the release date
see that comment was made a while ago
but i already know
i already know what it was about
december 13th is birthday december 14th
that's your birthday hey lots of
december uh birthdays
here's a question from the white wolf do
you think all the leaked dates are
changing their reveal plans at all i
don't think so i don't think the
because i think all of this is just
noise
i don't even know if it
like let's take for example the art book
thing because that's that's been a big
one as of late right because we saw
the u.s amazon listing of the official
harry potter art book
still says december 31st and has for a
while now
but then we started noticing i don't
know two weeks or so ago a week and a
half ago i was on vacation so i don't
remember the exact time frame of it but
people started noticing that
some of the other territories the date
was changing to december 6th
now here's the thing that a lot of
people missed on this i talked about
this in my video today
so rolling library that's an account on
twitter and a website
rolling library is initially the one who
broke the story
about this art book in general and when
they broke the story the date was
september so let's come out in september
actually september 6.
there we go now we can see it mew store
thank you so much for subscribing to the
channel all right we got that fixed now
i could see your names when we get the
subscriptions coming through
excellent
uh but yeah so rolling library broke
that story initially the release date
was september 6th
then it eventually changed to december
31st
except for amazon uk the
uk folks you probably know this the uk
one has said december 6th for a while
and so i think a lot of people just they
saw maybe one had changed and so then
they started checking a bunch of other
ones and seeing that oh they're all
they're all starting to say december 6th
now
and there there was somebody uh it might
have been i'm pretty sure it was wife
once a wizard
another fellow hogwarts legacy youtuber
i believe they were speculating that
maybe it is third party amazon sellers
in other countries
have potentially gotten something that
leads them to think december 6th is the
release date for the book
for the book
but that's not that piece is not
confirmed and even if it was confirmed
that doesn't automatically mean that the
art book is coming out that day and as
rolling library has maintained from the
beginning like until the publisher says
this is when it's coming out none of
this is final i mean we saw it change
from september to december like that so
all that stuff
is is it's just a lot of noise now the
game stop thing
is pretty interesting
the game stop thing is pretty
interesting because um if you all
haven't followed that one that was kind
of the main point of my video today
people got this email
i think yesterday and the date and maybe
today as well from gamestop it's like
something about xbox and but then in the
little preview so you know if you're
like checking your email on your phone
you're gonna see like a tiny little
preview of the email
well the preview says something about
pre-ordering the hogwarts legacy
collector's edition
i'm like wait wait what
then you open the email and there's
nothing at all about hogwarts legacy
so my speculation on that part is
well clearly someone at gamestop is
prepping and expecto go i'm pretty sure
this was expecto go
um who posted a uh
a screenshot of him in a gamestop where
they have like a hogwarts legacy
not gamebot like a really large picture
of the game as is coming soon
so like somebody at gamestop has gotten
or maybe they're just kind of looking at
their releases i don't know but my guess
and this was posted in a comment on that
video today someone was saying hey
what if it was actually
that was supposed to be for september
1st what if that was supposed to be for
exactly one month from today
and they just like they they copy-pasted
the wrong um
the wrong little um
blurb teaser whatever you want to call
it preview of the email
hello from sweden a welcome jason says
wife wants a wizard pretty pretty
different for me
yeah i mean we're all we're all uh i
think we all have kind of our own our
own unique style which which is good i
think that's that's healthy for the
community
but yeah i definitely encourage you guys
this is one thing i learned early on in
starting this youtube journey the the
thing about youtube is like
if any one of us so like if me or expect
a go or if uh
podcast now benjamin snow if any of us
have a video that takes off
it actually helps
bring up everybody because what happens
is that video starts reaching a lot more
people
and the way youtube works is like if you
go on youtube right now and you start
watching a video over on the right side
probably this way for the camera yeah
this way over on the right side of your
screen you'll start to see all these
little like suggestions
and it's like oh some of these are from
the same creator but then you like
scroll down and then oh wait this is
another one about hogwarts legacy and
then that can also influence what you
see on your homepage so it really does
help everybody so don't don't feel like
you just have to support one of us
honestly i mean there is plenty of
hogwarts legacy love to go around
cw evan says when do i think they'll
drop the release date
well i've been wrong already on that one
so i i thought it was gonna be like
right after the god of war announcement
happened i was like okay this is what
people have been waiting for
and we kind of did like across the
industry we started to see announcements
and other things sort of slot into place
some completely moved their games
out of the area completely so i thought
okay a couple weeks goes by then we're
gonna get the date
so i was i was thinking like mid-july
maybe
um so i i'm expecting it
any time from now
until
um like early mid-september hey steph
with the super chat thanks for the
content steph thank you so much for the
support thank you very much i i'm
telling you guys it has been a blast
covering this game
it really has and for those of you who
follow the channel for a while you you
know kind of my history with
through my videos you've probably heard
me talk about my history
of just loving this franchise in fact
somebody somebody was giving me a hard
time with the comments today about um
i posted a video just about uh the
thumbnail is after all this time and
it's it's really about those of us who
have been potter fans since the
beginning i'm talking before the movies
worth thing and if you're not it's okay
you know there i know there's some
younger ones out there
you may not even care about the movies
of the books you just think the game
looks cool that's totally fine too but
for the long time harry potter fans
man i mean this is just like it really
is a special moment
regardless i mean i hate to say
regardless of how the game pans out but
it really is just a crazy ambitious
solid green thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel welcome
welcome
but yeah i mean it's um
william brad said thank you so much for
the subscription as well
oh man let's see chandler tweeted
nothing going to be shown in gamescom
that's right i do feel like i remember
seeing that dylan which by the way this
was gonna be my top news item of
discussion today
have have any of you tuned in
let me actually pull this up here
did any of you tune in to the
let's see if they have anything on the
subreddit
today was the day of that developer
oh let me see i've got it pulled up in
another window here
the autodesk session i think is what it
was called so let's search
autodesk
this is another thing that chandler
tweeted about
so here this was from chandler um i've
seen some excitement around our session
at the autodesk vision series and want
to set expectations it's a developer
focused event with cool insights into
our development process and animation
pipeline but don't expect a big new
trailer or other information so that is
actually today that was supposed to be
taking place right before
i hopped on for this live stream
and
there was a post on reddit
this was about 18 days ago are you aware
of this so here's the
event right here this autodesk vision
series so i don't know i mean like
chandler said there's not going to be
any sort of uh major news breaking out
of it but i thought there might be some
cool little tidbits shared so if any of
you in the chat
have something on that let me know
uh do you think the game will have a lot
of bugs well
that's absolutely what they're
tackling right now for sure
and we've seen that because they've
shared it they they've shared it on
twitter
in a comical way which i i applaud them
for and it's been a it's been it's been
a little bit since they've shared
something like that uh but remember they
had the one with the centaur
just like flying through the area
and then they had um they had one with
uh sebastian's mission i think it was
or was that the same thing
i think that was a separate one right
but the main thing is that they're fixed
before the game releases
so
i don't think they're going to release
if it's full of a lot of bugs
i hate to bring up
i don't even want to say that the name
of the game
you guys already you guys already know
just when we start talking about bugs
it's on the edge of everyone's lips
everybody's just waiting to start
talking about
cyberpunk
and i i hate talking about cyberpunk
because it's like guys yes cyberpunk
taught the industry a lot of things but
not every single thing relates back to
cyberpunk okay
calm down people didn't want their game
to release full of bugs before cyberpunk
but but in reality there have been
lawsuits around that so it is it is a
big deal for the industry so i will say
i really think that that incident is
going to make everyone take an even
greater focus on
not releasing their games
in a in a broken state
so i don't think it will have a lot of
bugs because i don't think they'll
release it uh i think they would delay
it again
which
man as someone who works in marketing
myself that one is tough because i feel
like
i really feel like guys early december
for hogwarts legacy will be such
that is such a good time frame man
right when people are finishing up god
of war
there's not a lot of major releases that
would be competing for i mean it could
really just it's gonna sell well
regardless i believe but that early
december release would absolutely
crush i mean it would crush
now as we've seen i mean elden ring did
fine releasing what february games
released in january february march and
they do just fine
but oh man that early december would be
such a nice uh nice range
all right i gotta get caught up with
these comments here
uh let's see what do you expect
september first hike will they do
something special i think it's gonna be
mostly playstation
um but that that could be
everybody talks about that because it's
back to hogwarts day
the whole like the whole wizarding world
so
like um the official wizarding world
website they do a lot
around that that time
so people have thought maybe they're
gonna maybe they can loop it into that
it seems like
playstation has the marketing
exclusivity for hogwarts legacy because
that's really the only place we've seen
other than like the official twitter
account and stuff
um
and just be clear it is coming to other
platforms i still i get that question
all the time which for people who
haven't been following every single
thing i i understand um but to be 100
clear guys it is coming to pretty much
every major console out there even the
nintendo switch and it's also coming to
pc so when we talk about playstation
exclusivity we're talking about
marketing
exclusivity
jenna thinks we'll get a a hardwoods
legacy release date in august or
september yeah i feel like that late
august
early september is kind of like like
early september if they haven't said
something by
september 2nd september 3rd september
4th i think that's when people are
really going to start to get antsy and
be like okay you gotta give us something
even even if it's just even if it's a
delay
because you're looking at what october
november december
i mean that's three months three four
months right there
oh man you guys are dude the questions
you guys are asking so many good
questions
and i'm way behind so i'm gonna i
apologize i'm gonna have to skip over
some of these questions i'm gonna scroll
and catch up with you here you're a
wizard harry
sir barrymore thank you so much for the
subscription there
feathers
oh i scroll down and feathers is the
first comment that i see
uh liam nolan a thank you so much for
the sub as well
do you do
i struggle with pronouncing this word i
listen to expect to go pronounce it all
the time and i never say it out loud
because i don't think i can pronounce it
pious
a pureet
he says it just so clearly and perfectly
i do not i've never tried i'm gonna have
to get expect to go to teach me sometime
he's he's got the he's got the
experience with ballet so
wasn't there a rumor that the
playstation showcase is coming this
month august dylan yes that's a that's a
new one actually just a couple days ago
um but then the other part of that rumor
was like but it may get pushed back
it's like okay
okay
yo solid green thank you so much for the
super chat
let's see did sally green have a
question
i don't see a question from solid
green well thank you very much
appreciate that if you had a question
maybe just try to post it in the normal
yeah because for whatever reason it
didn't show me a question with it
i'll keep a lookout
so yeah thank you so much for showing
your support there
uh d
immortalis
oh i love this question
i love this question what do you think i
see you've been you've asked that
question a couple times what do you
think the floating wand is in the
pre-order bonus i think that's a
physical item
i think that is a physical
item
which let me see here i'm gonna try and
pull up
i have a bunch of uh
man i was cracking up looking at
whenever expect to go does its live
streams i love when he's like on his
computer going through his folders
and you just see like all
all these hogwarts legacy folders
with all these different and i'm like oh
man
i i feel you james i feel you
because i have the exact same
setup on my computer so i'm trying to
find the picture that i have of the um
of the the collector's edition stuff oh
here it is okay
all right so
this is uh for those of you don't know
this is what that question is referring
to here so this is
if you're not sure
if you've been living under hogwarts
legacy rock and you haven't seen all
this yet
basically some really eager fans were
looking around through the code
of hogwarts legacy.com the official
hogwarts legacy website
and anybody can do this i mean it's
something any of you can do like every
every web page on the internet you can
go and like view the source html code so
that's this is a legit thing
and they found some
text
that
spoke to
multiple editions of the game
collector's edition deluxe edition and
standard edition
which all of this was promptly removed
by the way i think it took a i think it
was like less 24 hours it was all
removed but i i tested it myself i
confirmed it this was totally legit so
it was from the official website
but it wasn't
i guess technically it was public
information but it wasn't intentionally
shared with the public so we don't we
don't know if this is for certain
well then a few days later somebody was
digging around even more and found some
actual visuals for it and that is what
this right here that you see on screen
is what they were able to find so you
see standard edition base game
deluxe edition base game thestral mount
dark arts cosmetic dark arts battle
arena dark arts garrison at digital
deluxe only on that one 72 hours early
access to the game digital deluxe only
and then a kelpie robe
so this
again caution none of this is final none
of this is confirmed even though it came
from this source this could have been
put in there temporarily as placeholder
where they were still talking about it
discussing it it may not have even been
finalized so we could get more than this
we could get less than this we could get
exactly this
or we could get some of this and some
new stuff that we haven't seen
and then the other one has pretty much
all the same stuff but also steel case
and then floating ancient magic wand
with book
i think that is it definitely a physical
item
that if it's the only physical item then
i mean other than a steel book which i
mean still books are cool i'm kind of
over them at this point
not to sidetrack too much here's my
issue with steelbooks guys is that they
never include the regular cover of the
game too or the regular game box which
drives me crazy
as a collector drives me crazy because
then when you display them on your shelf
you've got to like find a different
place for the steelbook one oh it's a
nightmare
in fact the uh the metroid um
you guys see i got i'm a big fan of
metroid got some metroid stuff back
there joel thank you so much for subbing
to the channel
uh but
this here
uh no wait that right there you can't
really make it out on the little camera
there but it's uh it's a metroid red
collector's edition well the one in the
us
it only included the steelbook box
the one in europe included the steel
case and the regular game box
like come on why does the us not get the
full one
anyway i digress
my point here is that it seems like in
this collector's edition that they have
here the only physical items
are the steel case and the floating
ancient magic wand with book
so if those are the only two things i
mean then this floating ancient magic
wand with book better be a pretty
incredible
piece right
now here's my question
is the book
the art book
or is it like
like floating ancient magic wand with
book
there's a lot of those things um
i don't know if i've seen it with a wand
but if you go around online and you
search like floating light bulb there
people have these on the desk where it
literally looks like it's floating in
midair i love this above this little
base so like is that like are they doing
something crazy like that
or is it just something that's kind of
in like a case that you put on display
and then is the book like underneath the
wand or is the book the art book i i
would see the book being the art book
but then why wouldn't it be a separate
entry you know
why would it be a separate entry
yo mary is here as well mary studios
welcome that is another name i recognize
from the comments
all right let's get back to these
questions here let's see
search html code
uh dylan i absolutely think we will see
a chamber of secrets easter egg
i don't think we'll be able to go in it
but i think 100
they will have something
hinting
at the chamber of secrets probably in
the in the girls bathroom
razor thinks in about 14 to 15 days
playstation will announce
the release date
janessa says listen retro i need this
game now
right don't we all
d jane do you think the game will do
well on nintendo switch
i i that is a million dollar question i
would love to know
i would love to know how it's going to
run on switch
i made a video asking is it going to be
a cloud version
and people are like no there's a
physical version you can see it on
amazon i'm like well
that's not officially a physical version
all that is is like they're showing you
a box with a switch on it maybe you're
just gonna get a code emailed to you or
a code you open up a box and there's a
code there
um
i i can't imagine i mean clearly the
switch version is gonna be inferior if
you're talking about how well it will
sell i think as long as it runs well
like if they can run a solid 30 frames
per second on the switch
what does a switch like i think handheld
is 720
well in handheld mode when you're just
uh not playing docked i mean so if they
can get a solid 30 fps
720 i think that'll be uh
i think that would be pretty good nerdy
giant yo thank you so much for the super
chat
let me scroll down and get your question
there do you think the day and night
cycle will be like red dead redemption 2
how do you think the day night stack
will work yo back to back super chats
expecto go here in the house what is up
my friend
smash the thumbs up hey that's right
expect they'll go they were dude they
were asking me about pureets earlier
which i'm
i struggle even pronouncing that word so
trying to do one
i'm gonna need you to teach me sometime
whenever we have like a we need a big
hogwarts legacy meet up
and i i saw expect to go he tried to get
alex from podcast now to do this as well
alex wouldn't bite so we're gonna have
to have like a session where expecto go
is gonna teach us all a pureet
oh man hey thank you guys for so much
for showing that uh monetary support
there with the super chat so expecto go
says uh visit three game stops okay so
that was your picture i saw somebody
post on reddit
which say a december 9th
16th friday release
ladies and gentlemen uh we have breaking
news here with expecto go
our correspondent live on the ground
early access december 6 or december 13th
dude
dude that is some good information man
it seems like the more
december 6 like keeps coming up keeps
coming up and i saw that podcast now put
out a video recently he's like saying
hold on
have all of us forgotten something here
with this whole 72 hours thing
because if if the game releases early 72
hours early then
so like which one would be the tuesday
release because wb typically releases
their game on tuesday so if what expecto
go is saying here the early access would
be like the
72 hour release date 72 hour early
access on december 6th
oh man three gamestops today which say a
december 9th december 16th friday
release with tuesday early access
dude that that date keeps popping up the
december 6th keeps popping up do we have
the stuff with the art book recently
clearly retailer something is happening
i think that's
what did i title today's video
because i was just like
something is going on with hogwarts
legacy
it is man something behind the scenes
pieces are moving they're getting things
lined up they're getting things in place
it's about to drop soon man i really i
i've been saying soon for a while but
these next couple weeks i i feel like
it's it's time man it's time
let's see if make sure expecto go didn't
make any other comments here that's
super interesting though
all right so we got nerdy giant um the
day and night cycles
that is one that i really really want to
know
i really want to know how it works
gretchen hey gretchen with the super
chat as well how many spells do you
think are in will there be fun
miscellaneous spells the pimple jinx or
aguamenti to prank npcs how about
imperial crucio oh yeah we got to get to
that one too
but the day night cycle see this is
what's fascinating about the day night
cycle stuff
let me go ahead and change this since we
kind of uh
finished talking about that for now
actually you know what let's see if we
can get the uh
i'd love to get that shot up
i'm pretty sure it's in one of the
hogwarts legacy blogs
where they have
there it is right there
all right so let's get that into hd
oh man we can't watch that too much
or hold on let's put it in uh
can i not drop the speed in this player
i guess not i'll just pause it right
here
or no i don't like that shot right
right there
because really with the day night cycles
the the piece that i can't figure out
nerdy giant
is it has to work well with classes
it has to work well with classes and
pretty much all i feel like i saw expect
to go talking about this alex has talked
about it benjamin snow has talked about
it
i think wife wants a wizard i think all
of us have talked about this at some
point
it's like
the cl how they handle the classes
i think will shape
how the day night cycles work
because while i would love to say that i
think it's going to be like
completely kind of open like um
would you say red dead i think this is
how red dead 2 handles it
and like how zelda handles it where you
just have this running like where the
game has its own internal clock that's
just running
and you can see the clouds moving you
can see everything changing i would love
for it to be like that but if that's how
they do it then i can't figure out how
they will make classes work because once
it gets night
then you can't be going to classes
and as
expecto goes significant other sue has
so eloquently pointed out
if you
if you do that
then people are going to feel this like
sense of urgency to like
oh man
i i have this allotted amount of time
i've got to get to this this in this
class and i don't know that they would
want to put that pressure on
on players now some people have said
they would like they want that like they
want to be like oh man i've got to
decide how am i going to spend my time
today this is sort of like persona
persona 4 golden and persona 5. they
kind of sort of do it like that where i
mean you have to choose like
which which um friend are you gonna
spend time with today
so they they do force you to make some
choices like that
i think they're gonna have to have a
system
this is a very long answer you asked me
for what my thought like what my guess
would be i still feel like they're gonna
have to have a system to where
you will see it advance
to a point so maybe there's like a
morning and an evening
and then
it won't it won't progress until you say
like i'm done
i'm done with i'm going to end the day
which is how the old harry potter games
did it right you would end the day and
then you would have a night section so
then you can go and
explore the castle at night and get into
all sorts of things like that so
i know that's not a good answer but i
just like if it wasn't for classes like
if this was like you're out of hogwarts
you're in aurora and you're just going
around and um
oh jason with a super chat as well maybe
the key date
hold on
maybe they key the day night thing to
classes or tie maybe you meant to say
tai yeah i think that i think that's
definitely
how those two connect
that's that will that will give us the
answer as to how the day nine cycles
work i think
all right now to gretchen's question how
many spells do you think are in somebody
was just asking me this on twitter as
well they were saying um did i think 70
spells would be too much i do think 70
would be too many
too many to expect
um so far we have seen
uh
i want to say we've seen like a dozen or
so
maybe even more than that hold on
where'd my hogwarts legacy page go
there we go
see if they have anything
i don't think there's anything in the
faq
oh there is there is a bit about spells
so my guess to that person who asked
asked me on twitter is i said probably
around 20 to 25 i feel like
um i love your idea of having some other
like minor spells that are sort of like
just for fun
that aren't necessarily for you're not
going to use this to solve
a puzzle and you're not going to use
this in battle but it's something like
uh
the pimple jinx or aguamenti to now
aguamenti you can use aguamenti for some
water-based puzzles for sure
so let's see what they say here i know
on record they have said in the trailer
in the gameplay chair they say dozens of
spells
so
here it says they would grow their
magical abilities by masting spells
brewing potions teaming fanta fantastic
beasts or taming magical beasts and more
appear by mastering powerful spells
learn to cast spells in addition to
classes and spells
and players mix and match spells yeah
here it is oh so they have this in the
faq too
mixing and matching dozens of spells so
officially that's what they're
committing to dozens of spells
let players define their combat style on
the path to become the ultimate duelist
now see there they're pretty clearly
speaking in terms of like combat
but yeah gretchen that's i hadn't
thought about some of like the minor
uh just like just kind of just for fun
spells
all right now let's get to that other
super chat let's see
oh we already yeah we already talked
about jason's yeah thank you so much
jason for the super chat appreciate that
all right let's let's check up check in
on these other comments that we got here
now the the question before i don't
think they specifically asked about
seasons
yeah they were asking about day and
night cycles but that also ties into
seasons as well
and this is where a lot of people start
to speculate well hey they said seasons
surely you're not gonna put summer in
the game
if
we're only gonna have one year at
hogwarts because then like okay you get
to summer
what happens then right
what happens
because you don't start hogwarts until
september 1st which i think technically
still
i think that is technically still
considered summer
in the uk i'm pretty sure
um so maybe like that's the summer and
then it shifts into
fall and then it shifts into winter and
then it's spring
i i really don't think it's going to be
more than one year that is something
i've stood by for a while but i don't
think people should see that as a
negative
because it really doesn't matter if it's
one year or if it's three people say oh
i want i want three years and don't get
me wrong i'd love to see that too
but it's really about how they a lot
that time how much time actually takes
place
because they control that in in how they
set the day night cycle
because it's not going to be animal
crossing you know where it's tied to our
real world clock 24 real hours in a day
is it going to be a one hour in the real
world is one hour in the game
i don't know i don't know but i think
that so they can make it as long as they
want it to be so i don't even if it's
only one year i don't think you should
worry that it's gonna be a short game i
mean obviously then you can make the
story even that much more enriching and
that much more impactful
um
i mean shoot though i would i would love
to have us go into summer
go go complete all our years at hogwarts
then we get to choose careers i know
when the early days of this game being
released people are like oh choosing
careers and i haven't made a video about
hey what if we got to do post hogwarts
stuff
so i don't foresee any of that
all right let's see we had another super
chat come through there i saw
oh but no question or at least i don't
see a question with it fire fire thank
you so much for uh for the super chat
yeah if i miss your your question guys
my apologies i think
most of them are showing up but for some
reason there's been a couple that didn't
show any questions so maybe it was just
just people wanting to show their
support
wonder what we're doing on the weekends
three windows yes that is another great
question
another
fantastic question
what will you be doing on the weekends
and then on the holidays like remember
harry would always stay at hogwarts at
least most throughout most of the
books he always stated hogwarts
um
so yeah what do we do during holidays is
that is that when we get like our our
big kind of exploration time
i don't know
a hundred likes 78 of y'all are slacking
might be like bully dude tristan i've
heard so many good things about bully
i'm ashamed to say i never played it but
i really did i i heard so many good
things and so many people who want
hogwarts legacy to borrow some of the
systems that they had
back
then i'm seeing talk of could be like
gta could be like bully could be like
red dead could be better than red dead
awful awful artful thinks you have to
end the day that's that's what i'm
leaning toward as well
it's going to be like persona 5 maybe
where you're always on a timer yeah they
could do something like that
now that would be interesting where it's
a timer but you don't necessarily have
to end the day but you can like see your
like your day timer or something
oh like i i just
uh james and sue were talking about this
in their last live stream too like
how the classes work is going to tell us
so much because we've seen there are cut
scenes for the classes so i mean there's
no way they programmed
geez how many how many days do they go
to school in hogwarts i have no idea 150
180 200 some somewhere in there i have
no idea there's no way they programmed
that many cutscenes in for like every
day it's going to be a unique
class
i could see it being like you have your
sort of um
like tentpole moment so maybe like
three or four big classes each year
where maybe something significant in the
story happens and then otherwise you're
just kind of going into that classroom
to kind of work on
practicing spells maybe they have
challenge areas we've already seen that
area in the trailer that's like on the
outside
where because we're starting late that
we're gonna have to get some extra
training in
official gameplay reveal let's just have
this playing in the background here
martin what if we can find a book in the
restricted section about parcel tongue
and that would allow us to open the
jammer secrets we know for sure the
basilisk was asleep right see that's the
thing if they do the chamber of secrets
and we have any kind of interaction with
the basilisk well then
it has to be something that either
everybody somehow forgets about so maybe
there's kind of a
memory charm or obliviate going on
somewhere in there or maybe we like
swear that we were never going to tell
anybody about what we saw in the chamber
something like that
two different game modes one strict and
one more free oh that's an interesting
idea they've confirmed that there are
going to be difficulties in for sure
kelpies underwater creatures we will
have to tame them underwater oh my gosh
hope there's not a field
gamestop official twitter just commented
on expectago's post
yo
this is awesome man
expect to go giving us like live
wait what this account doesn't exist are
you kidding me
are you kidding me
oh i forgot the underscore
oh do you not have it on your oh wait
hold on i bet it's on your replies
here we go
oh my gosh okay so here's uh here's
james you guys
gamestop already hyping up hogwarts
seconds he had an awesome 15-minute
combo about the release date preferred
platform to play the game with two
workers hype is real
so there you go you can see the game box
there
so they don't have a release date on
that so james was just talking to them
coming soon
and then after he posts it posts this
they right back
yo and we had another super chat come in
malcolm soto malcolm another one with no
question guys thank you so much for the
support that is very much appreciated
thank you thank you
dude james this is awesome man something
uh
something something something's brewing
don't know what
something is brewing
yo fire with another super chat fire
thank you so much let's see if the
question oh yes
awesome the question came through this
time
two questions first is how much do you
think the collector's edition will cost
how do you think the killing curse will
work and will it have a cool down or
something else
and mary said first term was 120 days
including weekends okay gosh i mean yeah
so
if we could even if you only had like
three classes which we know there's
going to be more than three classes
they've confirmed more than that
but even if you only had three
start to do the math there so yeah i
think they're going to have a collection
of cut scenes and different things that
can play when you go to the class
so how much do i think the collector's
edition will cost so let's pull that
back up here
because honestly like
and i know i'm saying this without being
able to see
a lot of this stuff
digital stuff guys
it just doesn't interest me at all
sorry avalanche like it it just doesn't
man
i just like i just don't care i i don't
care
early access that's kind of cool but
then in a way i sort of like
i'm not i'm really not a huge fan of
that either i
i want everybody to be experiencing this
game
like at the same time like we we all get
it
just whenever it release like that's
when that's the release date and we're
all playing it
it'll be fine though i mean we'll uh i
mean hey if you if you want to send out
some early copies avalanche
you know i'd be happy i'd be happy to
test it out for you don't get me wrong
so the the digital stuff like i it just
doesn't do a lot for me because my guess
they've already confirmed no micro 10
transactions so think about this you
guys
all this stuff i've seen some people
worrying if i don't buy this version
does that mean i'm i'm not going to get
the thestral mount
well only there's only one of two
possibilities here one possibility is
that they've already said no
microtransactions so they're not going
to be selling thestral mount separately
so either you can't get it at all
it's like completely locked out to
people who don't buy the deluxe or
collectors which i just cannot see them
doing
or it's what a lot of games do to where
hey if you buy this version you get
early access or not early access you get
it you unlock it like immediately but i
absolutely 100 think that thestral mount
will be something that everyone will get
eventually
you'll just have to wait longer uh in
the story maybe there's a story moment
where you get it instead
so i
i think all of this stuff the cosmetic
pack the battle arena the garrison hat i
think everybody will be able to get it
at some point you'll just unlock it
through like in-game currency not real
world currency
but anyway in terms of cost
so what what else are we get kelpie robe
i feel like kelpie robe has to be
a digital thing as well but it's kind of
weird how it they put it after the
72 hours early access like why wouldn't
it be before with the other digital
stuff
so we're basically looking at a whole
bunch of digital stuff here
and then the steel case and then
floating ancient magic one with book so
we got the base game that's 70 bucks
right there let's say
10 extra for getting access to all the
digital stuff
so that would take us up to 80. 72 hours
early access we'll be we'll be generous
and give them another 10 dollars for
that so now we're up to 90.
steel case
yo grim thank you so much for the
subscription
uh steel case
oh let's let's overcharge that one a bit
let's give them 20 bucks for that
so that takes us up to 110 kelpie robe i
forgot about but
we can include that with the other uh
if kelpie robe is a physical item well
that changes things i don't think it is
although they do call this one deluxe
like maybe it's like god of war how they
have the um
the regular collectors and then the
yotanar that comes with even more stuff
dude like imagine if this actually comes
with a full-on
kelpie robe
and dude if they're talking so much
about kelpies
does that mean we're gonna have
underwater stuff
don't chat don't let me forget the
underwater thing because joe my buddy
joe on twitter had an interesting
thought about that today
so what were we up to though we were up
to 110 with the steel case so then it
all comes down to this floating ancient
magic wand with book
if that's the only physical item then i
think it's going to be something big and
i think it's going to be something
really
nice the art book i think the current
cost the art book cost keeps changing it
was 50 now it's 45
i don't think it'll be that i think by
the time the official pricing comes out
i think the art book will be around 40
or so
so let's see if let's just assume that's
the art book so we're at 110 then let's
throw in let's throw in another 50 for
the art book
so that would take us up to about 160
and i'm being like overly generous to
avalanche here this is not how much
it's not what i think this stuff is
worth i'm just kind of guessing like
what companies have done in the past
so then that leaves the floating ancient
magic wand which would be the biggest
item
at least 50 for that so i would say like
199
that would be my guess on collectors 199
would be my collector's edition
guess i hope they keep it under 200.
i could see them going 249 but i don't
think they're going to go above 249.
then the other question how do you think
the killing curse will work will it have
a cooldown or something else
i think it's going to be my guess is
that it's going to be something acquired
near the end of the game
to where
i do think there's also going to be a
cool down but i'm thinking there's going
to be a cooldown for almost everything
simply because of that leaked piece of
the hud we saw
where one of them actually looks like a
little
um
well like it's like it's refilling
laser rio super chat as well laser thank
you so much we'll get to your question
here after we finish up answering this
one man you guys are coming in crazy
with the support thank you all so much
so i do think it'll have a cool down and
i think it's going to be a late game
thing but i don't think
i don't think they put it in that reveal
the first of all they knew how epic that
moment was going to be i don't think
they would put it in there if it was
only
like a one or something you do a couple
times
i could see it being the finisher that
they talked about in the gameplay
trailer you know how they talked about
the powerful finishers and they show the
character doing the lightning with the
ancient magic stuff there
i think it could fall into a finisher
and so it's it's a finisher if you
choose the dark path
and so like finishers will probably be
on a cool down
that's my guess that's my guess
philip on the collector's edition says
don't care take the money
stezza if we do see six and seventh
years is d now dlc that'd be an
interesting idea if they did it as dlc
but at that point it's like you know
what just go ahead and make a sequel
just go ahead and make a full-blown
sequel mew store also says max 250 with
a collector edition killing curse might
be a new game plus thing only oh because
it might be overpowered
i think we razer thinks we can find the
elder one in the game and the actually
and the collects edition will be the
elder one i mean it is it is an ancient
wand
if expecto goes right though
maybe that ancient one belongs to uh i
don't know one uh merlin by chance
dude maybe merlin had the elder one at
some point
jay ross would be much anticipation
excitement and speculation in this chat
right
i mean we've how long have we been going
let's see we'll be going for an hour
just like talking questions i love this
man i love this
then i don't would you guys ask so many
good questions it's like i don't even
need an agenda
i love i love
expecto goes live streams man they're
seriously the best i love he has
everything so organized he's got his
question of the week that he's gonna
talk about
um
then he has like something fun at the
end like where they do uh
they unbox various wizarding world
things and then the chat like the chat
just we just derail them we just
straight derail him see i learned from
you james i learned from watching your
chat i'm like i'm gonna go in with a
very loose outline because people just
love asking questions and we're that's
we're just gonna roll with that we're
just gonna roll with the questions
kelpies are underwater creatures do you
think we'll have to go underwater to
tame them okay
that right there
oh wait hold on laser did ask a super
chat let me get to lasers question and
then we'll come back to the water
we'll come back to the water do you
think the scene with nick in the state
of play is hinting towards a death day
party
that scene
that scene right there
the reason i'm so excited about that
scene is because
let's go back to media here
let's go back to the official gameplay
reveal
i'm excited so much about that scene
because we hear the character say
don't forget why i'm here sir
you're a wizard harry
yo you're a wizard harry
ains einstein hey thank you so much for
the subscription welcome to the story
here retrorecontour
all right i'm gonna let me mute my music
for a second
let's turn this up professors will not
be however you may recognize a few faces
all in good fun once the patrick lets me
join the headless hunt i'll be right
there with them this offering is sure to
win them over oh don't forget why i'm
here
don't forget why i'm here sir and
carrying what looks to be
i have no idea what that is but it does
not look like something pleasant that
i would want to eat
so
laser i think you could be right i think
this could definitely be hinting
that they're on their way to a death day
party if you guys remember from the book
so
the ghosts they have food at the death
day party but it's like rotting food
it's just like a terrible
awful smell
and that's because like they can uh
i've always wondered if they can
actually taste it
or if it's just like them imagining that
they can taste it i don't know
i don't know but i that's a that's a
good point i do think it's hinting at a
death day party yeah looks like they're
going somewhere but yeah the characters
saying don't forget why i'm here so
maybe our character is going to this
death day party
dude to learn something about
i don't know maybe an ancient wizard
like merlin
tone says here's what i'm hoping
gotham knights did a pc collector's
edition as well i hope they do it for
hogwarts ah interesting
one of thestral rope destroy road would
be sick okay
underwater stuff is there an event
tomorrow boxer uh not that i've heard
about no there was an event today
that was more like on the developer side
and some of the hogwarts legacy devs
were presenting on that i didn't get a
chance to watch it you actually had to
register for it uh and chandler said
there's not gonna be any big kind of
news breaking here but it would be um
kind of interesting on their the dev
process so i'm sure if there's something
big we'll we'll start to see some things
trickle out but yeah i'm not aware of
any other kind of event going on soon
okay so for the underwater stuff
let's hop back over here to twitter
and
so joe
machado
on twitter
joe's always hanging out in the comments
as well
so this looks like a wife wants a wizard
graphic
i think that's from wife once a wizard
but um so joe says it just occurred to
me
there is undoubtedly swimming in
hogwarts legacy thanks to this singular
detail
the diving board
why put a diving board
if you can't swim
hey nico thanks so much for becoming a
member here
unlocked some i think some pretty slick
emotes that you can use here in the chat
whenever you become a member guys that
um
yeah i i knew i was like i want to start
live streaming again and we got to get
some pretty slick
emotes that are uh obviously
hogwarts inspired you know
but yeah so so they said this right here
and sure enough you can see i talked
about this in my uh 55 things you missed
michael thanks so much for subbing to
the channel
um
if you've read the books you remember
this detail because you're a wizard this
is the prefix bathroom that we see
uh let's see amor poet hey thank you so
much for subbing to the channel as well
we um oh my goodness you guys coming in
with the subs right now let's go
janice thank you so much for subbing to
the channel
i'm so glad i updated these today
i was like oh dude my alerts i need to
update my alerts we gotta get some uh we
gotta get some hagrid euro wizard in
there
so
i love joe's thought here i do
but
but
i don't think it confirms
swimming in hogwarts legacy
i could see this just this little
section here
either it's just there for fun just as a
nod to fans because
this i mean this like
i i love this shot in the trailer
because this single shot alone shows you
the attention to detail in the books it
talks about how this this bathroom was
an extravagant bathroom and how the the
tub was essentially more like a swimming
pool and it even had a diving board and
it had all the different knobs remember
all the different knobs and they had all
the different colors of soaps and things
like that so i could see this totally
being like just a fun little nod to fans
having this room being so true to how it
was in the books and then you're just
gonna you know you could just walk by or
i could even see them having like a fun
little interactive section to where you
can just jump in
fully clothed you know
or maybe like have a mission where you
like you shove a friend in or something
i don't know
but so i don't think it confirms
swimming but i mean if we did have
swimming it's almost like they would
have to have a special
you need to like transfigure your attire
right
i mean think about the task and gobble
the fire they're wearing you know you're
obviously not wearing robes so
dude i would love swimming though
because then that opens up a whole
nother
layer because then you then you start
talking about mer people you start
talking about the giant squid you start
talking about i mean all the stuff under
the lake that they could explore
it's just like
the possibilities are
are endless with that
so yeah what do you got what do you guys
think like is is the diving board enough
to say hey
swimming is for sure in
mary if we're getting dlc wouldn't want
it to be for other years
would want them to maybe have it for
quidditch or something else yeah i'd
love to see uh quidditch as as dlc
i think it will be like
uh
gys after the story is over where you
can roam around like normal do you think
we'll start near the beginning
oh i definitely think that you'll have
um
you'll definitely be able to free roam
at the end whether they put you back
like right before the last mission
i mean because if you think about it
they're not going to let you if you get
to the end of the school year then
everybody goes home
that would be kind of hilarious though
if everybody else goes home for the
summer and you're just like like the
last the end of the game free roam is
you just wandering around hogwarts with
nobody it's like just the ghost and like
occasionally you'll pass some teachers
and that's it
no i would guess that it'll put you uh
like a lot of games do where it puts you
like before the last mission for the
free
roam rotten fish oh on the what nick was
carrying yeah looks like a casserole
it definitely looks pretty disgusting
100
death day party dylan says
wondering how we get into the prefix
bathroom because i doubt the student
knew
oh right yes if they're a new student
that's another good point mary so that
bathroom
um
yeah that that was the prefix bathroom
which i'm trying to remember now
oni savior with another super chat yo
thank you so much for the support
there's a part in the trailer where
water is flowing up to the ceiling as
the player is walking forward i'm
positive it's in the game
oh let's see you got a time i think i
know what you're talking about but
if you have a time stamp on the trailer
i can jump to it i think you're talking
about the scene where
they're in that area with professor figg
right
not there not there
okay here's professor figg
i think we've missed it
yeah i don't think it's this far in
yeah i think they're talking about that
big sort of wide room
where they're in there with uh professor
fig
clue viewer thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel
dude i wonder if it like holds all the
subs if the subs pop in at once grand
dark l
let's see if it does another one now
you're a wizard oh it did glenn creepy g
hanson thank you so much for the sub as
well
oh my gosh dusty beard is this dusty
beard
from our days on twitch
lauren d thank you so much for the
subscription as well welcome
dude dusty beard
it's got to be the same dusty beard it's
got to be
william as well something to the channel
thank you so much guys uh yeah we passed
uh 25 000 subs today abel with the sub
as well
jenna says yes we need to swim in the
pool
oh i mean hey we know that they're
including
we've got all those different um
outfits
so maybe there's gonna be some uh
aquatic attire for us as well
oh let's see hold on i saw another
if you search hogwarts legacy concept
art first video is one picture from
underwater all pictures were in the
gameplay oh martin says all pictures
were in gameplay i have to look into
that
ashton just finished reading the fourth
book and one part
uh mr
i'm not sure if it's mrs weasley comes
to see harry she's in
her time saying there was no whomping
willow right so the and the gatekeeper
or gamekeeper was a man named ogg yeah
so the womp the whomping willow
the whomping will that we remember
from the harry potter series
should not be in the game
however
a whopping willow is just a type of tree
i've i have a video all about this too
we've been making videos in hogwarts
legacy for a while now we've explored
quite a bit of the
all the little intricate things because
it was in the uh let's actually see if
it's still on there
i don't want to close this out but
for the longest time
yeah i'm pretty sure it's still in the
uh
yeah right here like this tree that is
clearly
a whomping willow
i i i think it's meant to be a whomping
willow
flukey with the ten dollar super chat
flookie thank you so much
um so i whomping willow there could be a
bunch of these
and it's not it's just not the whomping
willow that we see
in the in the series
uh not sure if anyone already has this
what is the approximate length of the
game my friend can't agree he thinks
it'll be as long as persona 5 royal
by the way love the content been binging
your vids yo thank you so much flukey i
appreciate that and appreciate the super
chat as well game length is a really no
one's asked that tonight actually i
don't think but that is a a common
question
i feel like
oh man
i gotta be careful on this because
everybody loves with this game everybody
talks about managing expectations
and i i've kind of always been on the
other side like dude imagine imagine the
world imagine what you want let your
hype go crazy i don't care i mean i love
getting said about games
but even i before that state of play
gameplay reveal even i was like okay
i have kind of in my head what i think
this is gonna be
and so i tried to kind of lower my
expectations a bit so my expectations
were here going into the state of play
i'm like okay let's let's bring him down
to about here and if they can hit this
i'll be happy and then that state of
play happened and
what they showed was like
through the roof it's honestly one of
the reasons that people hate when i say
this so apologies in advance you guys
people hate when i say but it's one of
the reasons that i immediately was like
the game's not coming out this year i
don't feel like it's gonna come out this
year
because they they showed
just like they're trying to do so
much i mean they are trying to put in
all the different systems like like the
whole menagerie thing
like even in my wildest dreams
fernan subscribe to the channel as well
thank you so much even in my wildest
dreams i never imagined that we would be
able to have our own little area inside
the room of requirement
dbl with the sub as well thank you so
much
it's where we can like
have pets and
have our own little custom home big mac
with the sub as well
it just blew my mind it blew my mind
and so
i think the game could potentially be
longer than i had originally
anticipated i really do
i feel like
a good dude oh
i might have to turn off the hagrid or
wizard don't stop the subs please keep
the subs coming
but hagrid dude you kind of i mean you
keep interrupting me a little bit hagrid
you keep interrupting me with the you're
a wizard harry only save your super
chatting thank you oni oh man i feel bad
you didn't have to super chat for that
14 minutes okay let's go and uh
i'm gonna stop it right
here so we can watch this
oh yeah
oh yeah somebody was right somebody said
right after the avada kadabra um but
answering so let me let me give an
answer to flookie here i've been why i'm
waffling it's what i'm doing flukie i'm
not i'm not committing
i feel like if they can hit a 30-hour
story
like that's not doing everything that's
like you know you're sticking to the
story
25 25 to 30 hours i feel like i would be
happy with that
and then maybe if uh to like see and do
everything 40 50 hours
and then
honestly if they do more than that if
this ends up being like a 100 hour
or more game like dude i'll be thrilled
i think what will increase the
replayability of this game obviously
depending on how much they lean into
that light and dark
are we that is something that
i wonder if they haven't pulled back
from a bit because early on it sounded
like oh man choice is going to be a big
deal
you're gonna choose your path and and
it's not like they're
saying we're not gonna be able to do
that i'm not saying that but i just
don't feel like they've talked about
that very much
so
i mean is it gonna be like like infamous
where you have
different endings is it gonna be like
mass effect style with all these choices
uh like how how exactly is all that
gonna work because that is something
that would extend the replayability
right because then you'd wanna go back
through and you wanna play
as evil uh maybe you wanna play as an
evil hufflepuff
hey they
i'm sure they exist
not a lot of them but i'm sure there's
some of them out there
so things like that would increase the
replayability as well
but yeah i i do feel like it is gonna be
a
i mean when they say open world action
rpg
um when they started talking about all
the stuff surrounding hogwarts as well
as the menagerie stuff that's when my
mind was really just like
started opening up to oh wow okay
okay
this is gonna be bigger than we thought
this is gonna be bigger than we thought
all right so let's get to oni's uh so
oni was talking about there's a scene
where you can see water
let me go back up here
as the player is walking forward water
flowing up to the ceiling
all right
so we'll watch it in normal oh
whoa okay
that scene right there okay so it's not
the scene i was thinking about let's
slow this down go to 0.25
see if we can kind of piece this
together here
as they uh the character ak's the goblin
okay this is interesting so over here
kind of on the sides you see what looks
like this swirling fog because initially
i was gonna say oh that looks like fog
to me but you're clearly talking about
this
this definitely looks like water right
here so why is our character just
our characters just like casually
walking
oh and then they they cut away too quick
they cut away too quick obviously they
don't want us to be able to see
i mean it almost looks like the material
that's in the uh pensive
but then i i could i could definitely
see water too i mean you see this kind
of swirling
i feel like if this was
i feel like if this was full on water
that our character would be i don't know
starting to like stagger i mean maybe
they do maybe maybe they cut away right
before the animation where they
start swimming
you know
but yeah i hadn't really ever thought of
this as uh
let's play with you one more time here
at 0.25
i'll hear what you guys think there i
mean because it's like you see this
swirling
almost kind of forming dude maybe it's
something with the ancient magic
looks like a spell effect
surrounding the character
possible
yo another super chat coming in from
carlos
vibes uh
good vibes good vibes uh carlos thank
you so much for the support on the
channel very much appreciated
oh we're talking about patronus now
runespoor somebody's patronus is a
dragon
somebody says um an asparagus oh that
that's that's an interesting one
oh that's funny
dude when i initially took the patronus
quiz on um wizarding world
what did i get
it was something so obscure
oh
i can't remember what it was let me log
in here real quick
it was something
i want to say a shrew but it was
it wasn't a shrew
currently no what i don't have any saved
emails for this are you kidding me
all right if i don't guess my password
right the first time then
wait wait oh i got it
yes
oh it was a tortoiseshell cat
was what it
said was my my wand here when i took it
but um
i never felt like that was right
and then i have since taken other
tests that obviously you can't do the
i still don't even think it was a cat
though
i do not remember it being a cat maybe
that's my wrong uh wizarding world
account there
oh goodness but um
then i took another like on some other
sites that take all the pottermore
questions
which i feel like that is the true way
if you take all the questions into an
account so there are these sites out
there they do this for sorting as well
where they take all the accounts into uh
or all the accounts they take all the
questions into account
and on that one i got dolphin
i got a dolphin for that one
only savior with another super chat
slytherin
where are you at
yo
dude wait can i not
it won't let me chat here in the uh
wait does obs not let me chat how do i
chat in my own
i was gonna try to hey nico with the the
ravenclaw emote there
lauren says hippogriff oh that'd be cool
got some ravenclaws in the house you can
see the bottom of the black lake in the
back windows of the slytherin common
room right yeah
oh brown bear that's an awesome patronus
brown bear is awesome
patronus is a vole expecto patronum
squeak
dementors ah
white stallion man a lot of you guys you
guys got some pretty uh
you guys get some good patronuses
patronuses patron i think it's
patronuses right
yeah patronuses
yeah so i i say dolphin is my patronus
which by the way
for those of you who haven't seen this
this is like seriously one of my
oh wait
i'm gonna have to go back through my
this is one of my favorite things
somebody uh a fan made this
for some of their favorite hogwarts
or not hogwarts harry potter content
creators they made this
it's uh aj aj draws on twitter
and
so he had asked me a couple weeks in
advance like what's your wand and
patronus
i was like okay so i told him and like
this is why i wanted to know this one's
me right here
which i have now set as my twitter
profile picture
but yeah i love this dude this is just
so epic
so epic expect i'll go with the mandrake
just makes it oh man it's so good
so good
otter scottish deerhound
hufflepuff with hobbit home lord of the
ring oh yeah the hufflepuff common room
looks so good
don't remember what your wand type was
only patronus being a dolphin hey let's
go
slytherin common room in the back kind
of resembles snake skin ah fun fact did
you know the hufflepuff common room was
actually inspired by the shire i do
think i
i mean clearly you could you could tell
from visuals it's
pretty close but i didn't know if that
was ever actually confirmed now one
somebody was talking about um
i was actually looking for the scene
when they were first talking about water
i was looking for that scene with fig
oh let me go back to normal speed
with fig where you're in that room with
all of the
oh it's gonna be right here
nope hold on maybe after this
you think i would have this all
memorized at this point given how many
times wait what i thought it was like
right after the
the other fig stuff
okay here's fig again
oh wait was that it nope oh i gotta stop
at this one though because this is
seriously like
this might be my favorite combat moment
of the entire trailer
expelliarmus and then a pugno on the
sword
oh my gosh like first of all just look
how fluid this combat is right
like you've got the little dash ability
you got the expelliarmus then you got
the pug no
oh it's so good
another pug no right there
i'm still not thrilled with how they're
using accio
because it's not supposed to be if i
remember right i don't think it's
supposed to be usable on
living beings
but hey
they can take some liberties
hogwarts legacy watch all concept art
there's the underwater pick martin says
oh there was yeah you wanted me to
i'll check that out here
i'm trying why can i not find the scene
oh wait
just gonna let it play
just gonna let it play and we'll uh
we'll see it when it pops up
that's your favorite combat scene as
well yeah it's so good
someone just put me to sleep until
december 6. i mean
maybe that's the date we don't know for
sure yet
although the uh the stuff expect to go
was talking about earlier it gets me
hyped
accio in the armor yeah
close
close
i'm just imagining like you're like
ripping off goblin
shirts
you're just accioing and the goblin
shirts just go flying
oh goodness
why do i think that scene
uh with fig and goblins gonna be a major
character choice
i feel like that scene is super early in
the game
so i don't know maybe there's a
character choice movement there early in
the game
it's possible like maybe you have to
like agree with fig or or side with ran
rock at that point
oh wait here we go i thought it was
early
right here
scene here i have always i've tried to
figure out what exactly this is
underneath their feet so clearly it's
not
i mean maybe it is water
and they're just on the like this glass
area here
but then it also looks like it could be
a landscape like it could be a map
of the surrounding area
and then like like what are these little
uh
little timelines blocking it a little
bit right here but
they're like these little
three kind of circles here
like what exactly is this room clearly
this
this shot right here
i think the ancient magic is a power of
detection for our character so like they
can detect this ancient magic like you
saw right there our character touched
the wall
and then this ancient magic that we
possess i think is what is able to
open up these certain areas to get us to
something that's a power and that so
that's why ran rock wants us
is to be able to get him into these
different areas of power and i think
those different areas are going to be
the dungeons of the game oh my gosh
i love this little detail you know the
little hogwarts legacy flame i'm sure
many people have pointed this out but
look at that right there
you see it right there in the mirror as
we also see gringotts there but there's
the little like in the main hogwarts
legacy logo right there
so then he taps it it goes solid so then
right here it's like all these different
portals opening up
i think these are going to be how we get
into the different dungeons of the game
3d map like an opal floor
hufflepuff common room oh yeah hold on
let me go back to uh
i think it was martin was saying about
the
where did it go
where did it go 220
okay let's see if i can find this
i'm just going to open it up in a
separate window i'm all just any time
that uh
oh wait not that one this one
anytime i'm opening up random videos i
just want to make sure that i'm
not showing something that i shouldn't
be showing on here
all right so hold on you told me the
exact
awkward sexy watch all concept art
it might help if i typed hogwarts legacy
in there too
hogwarts legacy watch all concept
art and 220
quiet you advertisement
all right so 220
all right let's pause this one
bring this over you're a wizard harry
yo corbett thank you so much for
subscribing all right now let's see if
they come in bunches again maybe they're
kind of like they hold
they hold them and then
pop them all at one time
crickets okay no all right maybe i'm
wrong okay so this is 217.
oh by the way let's give credit to this
uh
infant terrible is the person who
uploaded this e-n-f-a-n-t terrible
so right
oh that this so yeah this is definitely
not concept art for hogwarts legacy
i don't think
because that's that's hairy right
i feel like this is a i feel like
they're shifting into uh
the one above looks like that is
hogwarts legacy
but this i'm almost positive
or am i am i remembering wrong guys
help me out here
i feel like this is a harry potter
shot
but then again i do remember something
about this being with um
haven't seen what expectago has said yet
oh he was he just popped into the chat
earlier he was at gamestop today and
they've started putting up some visuals
for hogwarts legacy talking about it
coming soon and he was told he talked to
a couple different employees
and so what they are saying is december
6th
for early access
and then that friday which i guess would
be what december 9th as the
release date
or
december 13th
for early access and december 16th for
the full release now this is gamestop
and then they also um they responded to
one of his tweets
in an interesting uh like
excitement
all right i'm scrolling down to see what
you guys think about this
goblet of fire ghillie weed scene
martin i got fooled i guess
yeah i'm almost positive that this i
mean i could see why you'd be fooled
though because this before
like i think that
that might be hogwarts like i see
concept art
oh maybe not
that definitely is right there that
one's definitely
hogwarts legacy concept art
yeah but that one i'm almost positive
that is a shot of
from goblet of fire
let me see if i can find it i'm gonna
i'll let this play
uh harry potter
goblet i want to say that's a pottermore
i'm pretty sure that is a pottermore
artwork
let's see pottermore
artwork
archive this is all saved
online
because when they when they revamped
pottermore and changed it from
changed it from pottermore to
wizarding world we lost a lot of the
artwork
oh dude where is this site
archive here we go internet archive
pottermore materials first version no
that's not what i want harry potter wiki
oh they make it very hard to sort here
it is it was uh i knew i'd found it
somewhere it was on reddit somebody
actually archived it in
oh they archived it in their google
drive
i saved them all so i
i saved them all on my computer because
i was like dude if these ever i like to
use them sometimes in videos to kind of
uh
change things up you know especially
before we got the big 14 minute trailer
because i was like man i'm so tired of
the same
trailer playing in all my hogwarts
legacy videos alright so artwork
yes so this is
artwork there you go right there
from the black lake this was from
pottermore
and it is a shot
of the um goblet of fire that that task
really awesome concept art though
for sure
which i mean seeing a shot like this
dude
i mean harry's got his robes on right
there
so they can make it work
maybe we can get access to some ghillie
weed if they if they wanted to have
underwater oh my gosh can you imagine
like you start the game and you're
swimming underwater but you're very
limited because you have to keep coming
back up for air
and then you later you learn how to uh
start making giliweed
that would be so cool
so yeah i'm pretty sure that
yeah i have a file a folder on my
computer called pottermore
now i have one with all of the names so
let me go through
grouped by book
yeah that one is uh harry and the great
lake mer people second task
dude check out this one
oh man
the artwork that was on pottermore was
so
good
so good some of my favorite
pieces of art for the entire series are
on there
here's something they borrowed uh for
hogwarts legacy
look at that
got the troll heads on the wall this was
of course in
grim old place
this is something i pointed out in my 55
things you missed video
it is so bizarre
i'm trying to figure out why is that in
the trailer
why do they have this in uh
pretty sure it's right here look at this
look at this
why in our own little um
dude this this wizard
the person in this scene has to be going
down down the dark path right
you have to be going down the dark path
one of your uh oh wait ellie predicted
cursed child hold on i gotta read this
voldemort's daughter before cursed child
came out thank you very much could
revamp her and make her an old lestrange
ancestor i wonder how they'd react wait
what is uh
one of my
one of my original characters is that
what you mean
i'm not sure if you're talking about for
another game or if you've done like uh
fan fiction writing or something
i think the eat slu
eat slug spells in the game
somebody earlier was asking about if i
thought there would be very many of the
uh
you know like fun spells that aren't so
serious
eat slugs would be a good one
eat slugs would be a very good one
a lot of you talking about how you think
that
fig or one of the teachers is going to
turn out
to be uh evil or kind of working for the
dark side
i almost feel like it's inevitable right
i mean that's
there's got to be some sort of twist
i i'm hoping the twist is that
because everybody everybody always
gets up in arms about
goblins and i mean rightly so and even
even in the wizarding world like they
admit that they did not treat goblins
all that well
now goblins are
it's hard to know too like how
they're like such a different culture
and and some of the ways that they do
things
you know it may not have been compatible
with wizarding society so they may have
needed certain laws in place but there
are some things that the wizards just
definitely didn't treat the goblins
right on so it'd be really interesting
if they explore some of that
and maybe by the end of the game you
actually realize oh
ran rock is not so bad and he's got a
point
and then you find out there's actually
something else going on so
one of the
expecto go and
you know you guys who watch james you
know he's always got a big theory a new
theory
and his big one for a while has been
like the impact of merlin in this game
and that merlin's gonna be very
important well now since hogwarts legacy
showed that latest little clip with the
statue actually the statue right there
in the background it's not that exact
statue
but it this appears to be a statue of a
woman that we see in multiple spots in
somewhat different poses sometimes she's
uh she's holding something and then in
the uh
and the one that they just showed on
twitter
she's she has her hands like this but
she's not holding anything
maybe this is a nod to morgan lafaye or
morgana
who
according to which arthurian uh stories
you're reading
um
in some she's good in many she becomes a
rival of merlin's an evil character and
i'm pretty sure
she has her own
wizard card
in from the old harry potter video games
morgan le fay wizard
card
let's see here there she is
wait why can i not
well
i don't know why it's not letting me see
the other side but there there's the
there's the front of it
morgan le fay let's go hp wiki
okay so hp wiki morgan le fay
more commonly known as morgana was a
medieval dark witch famous for being the
enemy of the legendary wizard merlin and
the half sister of king arthur morgan le
faye was born and lived during the
middle ages she was known to have had a
half brother arthur
uh during her lifetime morgan la fle la
fay played a role in numerous events
through her powerful magic and healing
skills
she was an animagus
taking the form of a bird i always
hesitate on how to pronounce animagus
because
i i think that don't the movie say
animagus
and then i've heard animejus before so
animagus is what i'm i'm going to stick
with
dude you want you want to get comments
if any of your fellow content creators
out there
and you want to know how to get more
comments on your
harry potter and or hogwarts legacy and
or
lore of anything videos just
mispronounce a couple things
just try that one mispronounce couple
things you'll get lots of comments trust
me
anytime dude i even like
sometimes it's unintentional and
sometimes it's like nah that's that's
how i prefer to pronounce it my favorite
one is um
so
hold on
this is my favorite one
[Music]
right here
[Music]
so harry potter names and words we
pronounce wrongly for years
this one right here
i in a video pronounced it canutes
and people lost their minds they lost
their minds
not everybody you know just a select few
and so i'm like okay i gotta
gotta give you guys a bit of a history
lesson here on this some of you've
already heard the story you're like oh
here he goes again here he goes again
talking about the canutes
so
back when the harry potter books first
started coming out
scholastic set up a website which you
can still find through the wayback
machine
that was a pronunciation guide and this
word on there i i'm telling you guys you
can't you can't hear the words anymore
because it's flash and wayback machine
won't play flash but i promise you guys
they pronounced it canutes
however
on the audiobook
um
and here in this wizarding world
article
they say
canuts
which i just don't like most people just
think it's nuts
and so they think it's silent and so
they're like this dude's pronouncing the
k in nuts this is crazy and so you can
see here surely nuts behaves like nose
and has a silent k right wrong again
while we were running around saying nuts
harry ron hermione and everyone else in
the wizarding world purchasing goods and
services with galleon sickles and canuts
we didn't canal that
there you go so if you guys didn't know
that now you do
now you know that
also some talk about polyjuice potion
yeah i think paulie juice potion is
definitely in the game
i think that is all but confirmed in one
of the blog posts because they talked
about the importance of uh
just called it nuts i mean that's what
most people did right that's what you
would assume that's like you know the kn
it's gonna be like knife
hagrid said canuts in the movie did he
was it the first uh it would be the
first movie right
that's probably the only moment where
it's
i think i pulled back up that clip now
that you mentioned that i think i pulled
that back up but i've i've always
wondered for years
when the chain i mean rel the change had
to happen relatively quick because
when they did the audio books they said
canuts so actually maybe the audiobook
changed it and then they just went with
that
because i i promise on that scholastic
website i'm gonna have to see if i can
um
let me look this up way back machine
scholastic
as i said we won't be able to hear it
pronunciation guide
oh come on
let's try a different way of searching
for
it oh wait so in november 7 2007
snitchseeker had an article harry potter
or scholastic updates
potter pronunciation guide
let's see if this article even still
works
you can access the guide here yeah if
you just try to go go to it okay now
let me go to way back now i have the
exact link
enter a url there we go
oh yeah 2007 2008 that's when we got to
jump in
that's what we gotta jump in here to the
wayback machine
all right we'll try february
22nd of 2008.
yep see
here it is guys
i told you
it existed but we can't listen to it
because
find out how to say hermione ilops and
azkaban using our handy audio guide i'm
telling you dudes i was obsessed
so i i remember looking it up here and
it was uh it was totally canutes is how
they pronounced it there
now mugglenet
also has a pronunciation guide and last
i checked let me see if they still have
theirs this way
last i checked they still actually had
it matching yeah look at this
knut
because they were going based off
the um
the the scholastic pronunciation so i
would love to hear the reasoning for it
one day it's probably not
that interesting at all
and then another one that the movies
actually changed
was uh oh now see this one they
this one they do have accio on here
that is not how uh it in in the
pronunciation guide it was originally
ossio
osseo
that's how it was pronounced and then
the movies changed it to accio and that
just kind of stuck
all right enough i'm like
we're like getting super deep here
camp not wait wait are you saying nut
are you saying knut are you saying
[Music]
so if you want to be if you want to be
100 correct by what the wizarding world
official website as of
that article is saying it's it's
and that's what's in the movies that's
what's in the audiobook so there you go
i still like to say knute but hey
mostly now because it just makes people
angry
i listen to the audiobooks a lot highly
recommend it oh the audiobooks are so
good
they're so good both jim dale and
stephen fry
like do do a fantastic job
oh man a wizard in the hopping pot
i've been thinking about doing a video
on this
if you guys remember in this shot right
here of the um
wait what the heck hold on
this
oh my gosh that portrait right there
why am i getting morgan lafaye vibes
from that
that is giving me morgan le fay vibes
yeah dude imagine if like oh
morgana has
i don't know left something behind and
it's like
this this this competing ancient this
ancient magic of the the two ancient
rivals of morgan lafaye and merlin
i think that'd be so cool
i really do
family guy cool with fives
oh goodness
my one core unsung hero is phoenix
feather
phoenix feather in my wand core
reason why our robes preferably the arm
sleeves look different compared to other
students
i wonder if they let us have a certain
level of customization over the robes
or if
i don't know maybe if it's like because
we're
we're starting late and they they just
want to say like hey this is the guy
that doesn't know as much
that'd be terrible no i don't think
that's why i think it's probably just
like a customization thing but but
you're right i mean it is slightly
different and i think
let's see if we can uh in that scene
with
because ours are pretty consistent i
don't think ours changed much throughout
like our our hood is a little different
and then also the like right there you
can really see it
so natsai i mean both even in gryffindor
so the cuff on the arm there is
different
and then ours has this kind of gold now
some people have been saying maybe we're
a prefect but i mean
i can't see us being a prefect if we
don't know we don't even know that much
about the world we're new to hogwarts
who knows if we're completely new to
magic i kind of think we are
but that part i could be wrong on maybe
our parents have been teaching us or
i don't think we went to another school
though i mean
why would we have to catch up there
there's got to be a reason that we
haven't been practicing magic maybe we
were thought of as a squib but we were
in a magic family
i'm not sure but yes you've got kind of
the gold that's different this stripe
that runs all the way down
maybe it's totally customizable though
that's an interesting question
explains the change chain exchange
why can i not say that he explains the
exchange ah it's the double the ex and
the ex it's kidding me he explains the
exchange rates for all of the coins in
the cabin when he picks up harry in the
book but i think he explains it in
diagon alley in the movie i think you're
right i think right before uh
i think it might be right before e
now i don't want to i'll i'll get it
wrong but
i i do i do remember him saying it now
in the movie that you mention it
black oak one with a unicorn tail cannot
wait to be inside this world
yo jason have a good one
they talk about merlin's puzzles if he
left things behind it's sensible that
morgana has too hey good point rossi
right i mean
she's not gonna be outdone she's gonna
try and leave some things behind as well
but yeah i mean
even if merlin doesn't prove to be as
big as
a lot of us are thinking
i mean we know 100 he's confirmed to
have some impact on the game we see him
in the stained glass window they talk
about puzzles left behind by merlin
so even if he doesn't factor majorly
into the story
he's going to be a factor in the game
for sure which is exciting
different difficulties yes they are
confirmed yeah
that was confirmed in the i believe it's
in the playstation blog post
um
that came out after the gameplay trailer
let me double check here see if that's
the one
yeah right here
so it's this blog right here on the
playstation blog that came out this one
was the one right after the uh the big
gameplay reveal
so about halfway down the pay here a
little bit more than halfway down the
page
this section right here as a gamer likes
a bit of a challenge myself happy to say
that we've been working hard to make
sure combat has a depth and challenge
whether you want to experience the story
or make every swish and flick of your
one matter a range of difficulty options
will be available to meet various skills
enabling players to experience the game
in a way most enjoyable to them
which is good i think it's good that a
game like this has it
but what i want to know
is like okay so difficulty option
do the enemies have different attack
patterns because one of the big kind of
critiques of the combat in the trailer
is that for the most part i mean it
looks like they just you know
they're they're not really well i don't
know what i just did there
they're not really attacking you
at the same time you know
like this guy like watch this guy over
here he's kind of just so he fires that
one and then this dude here he's just
kind of chilling he's throwing his hand
up
this guy over here so that's been one of
the big critiques so the question is and
in higher difficulty
does that mean they're going to attack
faster or is it just like wait what in
the world
what in the world is this
i thought i was on the official
oh i was it just switched over to
yeah it's weird how the
the gift cat website does that
oh so i was on the official site but
then when i clicked in took me to gift
card that's what was going on
yeah i love so many of these shots here
that they put in this blog post that
some of which weren't even in the uh
the trailer like look at this i love
if you really want to see the detail
of the costumes and like the patterns on
the clothing
go in and look at this and make sure you
hit this little gear right here to turn
it to hd quality because by
default it goes to sd for some reason
looks really blurry
and then like ranrock right here
get a really nice look at his armor
i mean look at that man
look at that so good
and then there's one more like the the
scene this shot right here
dude like just
if you just try and imagine like what
the heck would we be doing
clearly forbidden forest
clearly night
and we're just
we're just flying through it slowly on
our broomstick like is this a story
section are we just out exploring
something big is about to happen in this
shot no doubt
no doubt about it
the way that's worded sounds like not
only normal settings like easy medium
hard but also more difficulty settings
you can change it could be yeah
i know um
accessibility settings
has been a really big thing for games
lately
which it's it's great to see them adding
more and more accessibility settings
that
make it so more people can experience
video games so
i would i would expect they'll have a
range
of those kind of options as well
excuse me
laser rio i hope peeves is a big part of
the game want to be able to randomly
walk into an area see them causing chaos
oh right
they're gonna have to have that that'll
be a really nice way to kind of build up
the
atmosphere in the world to where
dude if you've
if you've ever played resident evil 2
imagine if peeves is like a mr x
style where you like you never know
where he's going to pop up
and once he locks onto you he just like
follows you for a while
so what if you run into him one night
and like if he if he spots you and you
can't get away well then he just follows
you around the rest of the night to make
your uh
make it more difficult
how do you think jealousy is going to
play into this walking to hogwarts is a
figure a bunch of random powers like you
know some people are gonna be super
jealous oh yeah we we have to have our
enemies
we have to have our rivals in the school
that aren't going to be too happy with
us
and they've even talked about how we
arrive at the school a bit like harry
with some sort of celebrity status
because of what we've survived so our
character has survived
something
we don't really know what yet
some have speculated that it's a goblin
attack some have speculated that it's
something that our character caused
using with this latent
magical ability this ancient magic
but yeah how they'll they'll have to
have rivals in the game somehow
how much do you think we see or play
through prior to even getting to
hogwarts like the fig versus ran rock
scene
i definitely think that happens prior to
arriving i am undecided on
how much i think is cutscene and how
much i think is gameplay
because we see our character in that
different style of of clothing
i feel like you know what
if you go back to this scene like the
very beginning of the trailer when they
start talking about
uh like but first you gotta chew this is
what they're wearing right here like
this kind of coat and it's interesting
that both
i wonder if there's very little we like
so maybe this scene right here maybe
we're not customizing the clothing at
all maybe oh well no we can see there's
definitely different ties so we've got a
bow side here and we've got a standard
tie here so we know we can at least
customize that much but the shirt color
and the coat color is the same
i think this is our starting game attire
right here
and then once we
do the care oh man a man we should like
we need to like break down the
background of this because wherever this
is
is probably where the game starts right
i mean maybe we're just in our house
like maybe this is right after the
the inciting incident whatever it is
that kind of kicks off our
this ancient magic surrounding our
character
see then by the time we get to hogwarts
we have this sort of standard hogwarts
robe
which doesn't have that kind of gold
pattern on it and it doesn't have our
house yet because we haven't been sorted
just yet
so at some point between the scene with
fig
so we got the scene with fig right
here
so right there we see that's our that's
our starting game attire i'm almost
positive
so we have this scene with fig
at some point between this scene right
here
and arriving to hogwarts
we change a tire we change clothes now
let me see i'm trying to remember in the
little uh
in the carriage on the way to hogwarts
i don't think it shows oh yeah so look
so even right there we're in the
carriage are we on the way to hogwarts i
think we have to be
because
boom right there monday september 1st we
know the hogwarts express leaves
september 1st
so pretty clear we're not going to be
taking the hogwarts express
which i'm kind of disappointed about not
going to lie
kind of disappointed by that
but we're going to be taking the
carriage instead
so
i guess so we arrive at hogwarts and
then maybe we have a scene where
we go and we change clothes before we we
go into the sorting ceremony because
yeah then by the time we get into the
sorting ceremony we've changed into that
sort of standard hogwarts robe
and then once we get sorted
then we're here
but that is a great question white wolf
oh and look this right here
we're also in that attire
dude so maybe this is like a whole
maybe this is the tutorial section of
the game right here
and we're like getting ready to leave
with fig to head to uh
who knows though like that could be us
on a
on
winter break as well while all the other
kids are gone we're still there hanging
out with fig and we're doing some uh
other exploring and it could be
clothing that's completely customizable
it's hard to say
yeah that i mean that could even be
before we start school right there
what wizard families from the films
aside from the weasleys do you think we
will come across
so we know rookwood for sure right
because we've uh
that one's confirmed the weasleys
i would say
99 confirmed i mean they they said maybe
even a weasley or two kind of like they
were trying to tease us but
in reality that's
that's confirmation that the weasleys
are gonna be in there some of the
weasleys anyway right
uh so i could definitely see a lestrange
that is such a uh
a long-standing wizarding family
the dumbledore's i think dumbledore's
might be might be mentioned
we might hear mention of dumbledore but
in terms of actually going to school at
hogwarts maybe a lestrange
maybe uh obviously the weasley we talked
about
i i really feel like
that the nods to the original series are
gonna come in the form of
like little little easter eggs i don't
and i shouldn't say just easter eggs
though because clearly the world
is going to be respectful of the
original series but
i don't think they're going to try to
rely on the original stuff too much
which is one of the big reasons i didn't
think dumbledore was going to be in the
game because i think
they want to tell their own story and if
you start
if you start bringing dumbledore into
the picture well then
obviously dumbledore is a pivotal
character
in both of the main like obviously the
mainline series but then fantastic beast
he's also a major character in that as
well i think they want to stay away from
all that
so i think we'll we'll we'll see some
names pop up that we know for sure but i
don't think they're gonna be a major uh
major role in the game
when it comes to
customizing do you think we'll be able
to choose our patronus
so that we can match our house juan
patronus
that the the question about customizing
wands and customizing the patronus
that's a tough one because
i feel like in all the shots like we see
i'm pretty sure throughout the trailer
we don't see our character holding a
different type of wand
but they gotta have something in with
juan selection they have to because
that's such a key thing for people but
when it comes to the patronus that's a
tougher one because that's something
that you want to see take a
corporeal
form
and it's like how would they program all
of that in
how would they program all of that in
that's why i mean maybe they're not even
going to have the patronus charm in the
game which would really
be unfortunate because
we haven't seen like they showed
dementors in the first trailer but we
haven't seen any more of them at all so
who knows how how big of a role they're
gonna play obviously if they're not a
major part of the game then
it's not a big deal we don't even really
need to know that charm and i also have
to remember that is some pretty advanced
magic and our character is they're
starting as a fifth year so harry
learned it his third year
but we're getting caught up i i really
hope expecto patronum is in but
gosh i just don't know how you do that
because i mean people would be so
disappointed that they're
animals not in the game
i mean they could just do it like um
where it doesn't take a corporeal form
but then people would be upset about
that too you
know
all right guys i'm gonna if you got any
uh final questions i'm gonna try to wrap
it up here maybe go about 10-15 more
minutes it's been great we've been going
for over two hours be going almost two
and a half hours
and this has been completely like i had
i had a loose structure of things i
wanted to cover but you guys have just
been asking so many good questions
that uh i haven't even really needed to
go through that much so
so if you have any final questions
anything you want to add here before we
get to the end
phineas if phineas is in the game i will
lose oh i think phineas is totally in
i think he's totally in because even if
he's not headmaster he should be there
as a professor
and some people have thought the potions
professor looks i mean
at least gary oldman and movie version
of sirius he really does look a lot like
him
hey there's our boy peeves right there
yeah black for sure if if uh if he's the
headmaster yeah definitely is fig
confirmed to be a professor if he is i
wonder what subject he teaches
yeah they they they've said the
enigmatic professor fig
i think some have thought uh maybe he is
ancient runes i believe i saw some
people speculating on because we know
he's not potions we know he's not
herbology
we're
pretty confident he's not defense
against the dark arts that is the the
female professor that we see in the
dueling
area
so that would leave like ancient runes
uh divination i don't think he's
divination
we i'm pretty sure we see the divination
professor
um oh and we already know the charms
professor so yeah that really only
leaves
it could be care of magical creatures
could be care of magical creatures
ancient runes muggle studies
imagine that we take muggle studies in
the game
oh that'd be the one class all of us
would want to skip right
all of us real world muggles
he's going to be a friend of the player
uh kind of like a mentor yeah we hope we
hope he is a a true friend and doesn't
have more nefarious reasons
let's see you guys think dumbledore will
show up year seven i mean if if we go to
the sev our seventh year he has to show
up
that that's one of those glaring things
you cannot
if they go into the seventh year either
in this game or a sequel if you get to
year seven
dumbledore better show up that's a plot
hole you cannot like
we're i'm all for them taking some
creative liberties and not everything
has to be exactly true to canon but
dumbledore arriving that year
that's that's got to be an automatic one
right there
uh some people asking about myrtle yeah
myrtle myrtle wouldn't have uh died yet
because we this is uh 1891 so this is
before her death
but um pretty sure we know we're getting
nick we know we're getting peeves pretty
sure the bloody baron will be there
pretty sure the fat fryer will be there
um ravenclaw
should be there
ravenclaw's ghost
i'm trying to think of any of the other
major ghosts a lot of the portraits like
the fat lady circadogen
there's gonna be a lot of things and
faces we recognize even if they're not
like
living
they're not actively alive
unsung hero if it could choose one thing
to have in the game what would it be
one thing
i would say
this is a hard one to put into like one
thing but i i want the gameplay
to be
rock solid i want the game to feel good
to play so if i had to pick one thing
i'll say the combat because i think
combat's going to be a major part
combat with a with a balance of the of
the exploration as well
because even if the combat is just kind
of okay you can forgive that if the
exploration and the discovery
is really really good so i i just want
the game to run well i want it to play
well because i mean everything they're
showing
all of this that we see in the trailer
just looks phenomenal it just it just
looks so good it looks so fun
the promise is there it's all about how
they can deliver right
that's that's the main thing
that is the main thing
how long the game will be uh just purely
guess zach some people were asking about
that one earlier
um
i was saying 25 to 30 hours for the main
story
maybe 40 50 to do everything and
anything above that would be just
gravy for me
not sure about the fat fryer but um all
the other yeah all the other hogwarts
ghosts should be
fat friar do we have i'm trying to
remember the dates on that one i
remember looking all these up at some
point
oh transfiguration mary you're right
yeah that
we do see in the first
in the first trailer there's that shot
of them transfiguring the um
oh what is it i think it's like a
wardrobe
we definitely see but it's it's like a
cut scene it looks to be like a cut
scene we see a transfiguring there
so yeah we don't we don't know the
transfiguration professor either
so that could be fake
in fact that one i might say that one
might be the most likely
because i don't even know we like are
they gonna put ancient runes in the game
like what would you
although professor figg is the one kind
of taking us around to all these
different areas so i could absolutely
see him ancient runes with tie in
avalanche that released they better get
announced soon or early september yeah i
i mean i feel like any time i really do
i i do think
there are so many parties with this one
and what i mean by that is like
playstation is heavily involved
then you got avalanche the people making
the game
so anything they want to show avalanche
obviously has to get it ready
then you got wb
major major component of harry potter
then you have a portkey games
who are wb is producing this with them
it's
like the port key games label is what
they use for harry potter games
i mean so you've got some major
major companies at the table who would
need to sign off on any of this stuff so
they all have their own pr people they
all have their own marketing people so i
can just imagine the the email threads
that
guys like chandler are on to where
they're
you know deciding their marketing plans
and when they can reveal what and and
all of that sort of thing
but i feel like it's i mean any any time
between now and early september would
not surprise me
if we get into early september and then
we still don't have anything that's
that's when you start to be like okay
what the heck's going on
what's going on
anything with salazar slytherin
i think there'll be nods to all the
founders
and and easter eggs that we find in game
i don't know that they're going to
factor too much into the story
get to go to diagon alley djing asks oh
yes but not how everybody wants
yes but not how everybody wants
um clearly
gringotts is end
we've seen that in the trailer which is
in diagon alley i i do not think we'll
be able to go and explore all the diagon
alley shops
so i think we'll be in certain parts of
diagon alley
like gringotts but we're not actually
going to get to go and look in all the
little shops unfortunately
and somebody i saw earlier was asking
about they can did they confirm no
quidditch
no they have not confirmed it this was a
story that i broke
about um
some information that i've i've
been given
on behind the scenes
from uh
all i can really say is people who would
definitely know people people very close
to the game more than one so i i i
didn't i actually heard this months and
months and months ago
i heard this months ago that quidditch
wasn't going to be a playable thing for
our character it's still going to be
part of the world we may even be able to
watch quidditch games
i i don't know about that part that's
just me speculating it's definitely in
the world because we see quality
quidditch supplies
um
but i am i am very confident in the two
sources i have on this that it is uh
it's not gonna be playable unless
something that's added is like dlc
later on but yeah i heard this many
months ago and i didn't say anything
about it because i just heard it from
one person
again someone who would know but it was
kind of like
really i just i can't
i thought they had kind of teased it in
the trailer i thought it was i mean you
can go back and watch my live reaction
to the gameplay reveal i'm like
quidditch confirmed
i thought it was pretty clearly
confirming quidditch but then the more
things went on and it's like oh they
didn't they actually didn't show
anything of us playing and then if you
think about it story-wise it really
doesn't fit right i mean our characters
starting as a fifth year they're already
going to be way behind they're not going
to have time for quidditch
um but then here more recently i talked
to somebody else
behind the scenes again somebody who
would know
somebody with direct knowledge of the
game
and i said hey
i heard this a few months ago anything
you could say on it
and they were like
they they confirmed it like yeah that's
that's basically true there is no
playable quidditch so
that's uh that's the deal yeah
unfortunately i'd love to be wrong i
would but i mean i i think in the video
i said something like i'm 95 confident
unless two separate people who had no
knowledge that i was talking to
each of them
unless two of these people
just completely wanted to troll me and
and see me look like a fool with my with
a youtube channel
unless that's what's going on then it's
i'm pretty confident that it's not
playable in the game
plot twist the goblins are the good guys
think fig is the uh astrology teacher oh
we got some dates on the fat fryer there
mary says i made a video about how i
would do each class in the game and for
ancient runes and said they would have a
study
basically have us be able to read
anything in ancient runes i'll have to
check that video out i like that idea
yeah that's a
the class thing man if i could have them
reveal
if i could only have one thing revealed
i think that's what i would want to know
is how do classes work
like
how does the timing work what do you do
in the classes because something
everybody wants to do but it's like how
do you make that fun and engaging the
old games handled it and where
it was sort of a class but then you go
into this big challenge room
so yeah it'll be it'll be really
interesting to see how they did show us
writing a broom so broom broom writing
is in and even broome races is in
so i'm i'm i mean people are calling it
a rumor i mean i guess
to people who haven't
when you when you haven't talked to the
source like i have then i get it you
know it's it's still a rumor but i'm
i'm pretty confident for for quidditch
not going to be in based on who i've
talked to yeah
all right guys we're going to wrap it up
here uh keegan going to be a gryffindor
wife wants to watch me play hey that's
awesome
yeah maybe my wife's not a big gamer
either maybe i'll be able to convince
her to watch me play a bit of this we'll
see
we shall see
disappointed we'll never fight voldemort
ah
i mean there could be another big dark
wizard but i don't know i kind of want
him to stay away from the
if we had voldemort we had grindelwald
it's gonna be cool to have another sort
of evil in the world another sort of uh
bad guy or bad girl
right
morgan le fay hey it's possible
it's possible
all right man
i'm gonna go ahead and prepare to wrap
things up here
this has been an awesome stream guys
for my first stream
that
like
it's been so long since i've done a
stream
it's been so long
since i've had a stream
and to see the support and everybody
hanging out in the chat here all the
great questions i'm gonna try and make
this a regular thing i'm gonna try and
make this a
something that we do
once i would love for it to be a once a
week tuesday evening kind of thing
i'm not going to do wednesdays because
that's when expecto go does his thing i
don't want to conflict with that
i know i think alex from podcast now
usually goes a little bit later in the
week
so i don't i don't want to detract from
what a lot of other people are doing
if i can
but yeah we got some uh we got some big
things in the works for the channel guys
some some big things i'm excited
for the upcoming announcements
and i'm gonna try and maybe start even
having guests on
expect to go is one that i've already
mentioned that i i absolutely want to
have james on because
if james and i get together i warn you
guys unless we have like a hard out of
when the time needs to end he and i have
never talked we've talked over twitter
we've never talked face to face i warn
you guys if he and i get going this
could be like a five hour stream
he and i are gonna have to set some
clear parameters um i don't think alex
has announced it officially yet but uh
let's just say i am planning uh at some
point keep an eye on his uh channels and
stuff i'm planning at some point to be
on the live show that he does as well to
talk some hogwarts legacy there so this
has been a blast uh if you guys ha if
you just happen to stumble into the live
stream and you haven't seen the channel
before um check out the videos man
subscribe to the channel you won't then
you won't miss any of our actually the
way youtube works you will miss the
videos
because the way subscriptions work
subscription is more just like hey i
support what you're doing just want to
give you this little thumbs up the
subscribe button
um but then it doesn't even always show
you videos even if you're subscribed but
if you watch a lot of my videos you will
see it on your homepage more often than
not and if you have video ideas man send
them my way hit me up on twitter at
retrorecontour leave me comments i read
all the comments
and i've in fact taken a lot of ideas um
from viewer suggestions so
thank you all so much man all the
support and the super chats all the
support with the the new members all the
new subs and all the great questions
it has been awesome so we are definitely
gonna do this again soon seeing a lot of
you say you enjoyed the stream awesome
to hear awesome here guys thank you so
much
now it runs an ad oh man right at the
end
didn't i didn't i didn't even know how
ads work on uh
there was like this button that popped
up when i i brought open my other uh
window where i can see like all the
stream stuff and it's like this pop-up
said now be a good time to run an ad i
must have clicked on that
to get it to go away and it ran the ad
because on twitch they kind of auto run
ads but i usually don't like to run ads
on live streams if i can avoid it
but anyway
i mean dude that two and a half hours
went by like that for me if any of you
have been here the whole time hopefully
went by uh quickly for you as well
guys thank you so much
just before i leave i have to answer
this last question why are you reacting
to her are you french
no
i'm not i do get asked that question
though by a lot of french people
i found a lot of french people because
the word in in french it's actually it's
the way
they pronounce it i believe is like
reconcile
it is just a word that uh for those of
you don't know it means storyteller and
i obviously being a fan of harry potter
i love stories and really if you think
about it like what we do on youtube and
what we do on twitch is uh a lot of
times we're sharing our story with you
guys we're sharing stories from video
games
and i just like for everybody to know
that their their own story like your
story matters and that's really one of
the reasons that i
started a channel is for a place for
people to
feel like they belong man because this
this world is a crazy dark place a lot
of times and some people don't have
they don't have a community they don't
have family they don't have close
friends in real life and so
but this is real life right in this day
and age 2022 i mean this relationship
this internet
used to be it's it seemed like this own
separate thing you know it's like well
my real world friends no i mean this is
real guys this is the real deal so i
just want everybody to know that you
know your your story matters
and um
yeah so that's kind of the history of
the of the racketeer name no i'm not
french though not french at all
i want to get into more kind of like uh
one day we'll have more sort of
historical
retrospective style videos like the one
i did complete history of harry potter
video games oh man that that video took
me so long that's why i haven't done
another one because it took me so long
oh it took me so long
nico hey nico dude those emotes look so
good i love it
alright i'm out for real this time guys
out for real thank you all so much for
watching
have a great evening
and i will talk to you again
soon